it's Drake what about the allegations
that your tests and killing people have
you finished well I think we opened him
up I'm a reporter I found something
really bad and I have been taking a
whopper late and you just might survive
why would we do that
aren't you Eddie Brock
I used to be
October 5th we cannot just eat people
when I see it
do whatever we want
is there something you wanna tell me
nope
get to my eyes or walk away and you just
might survive how are you doing Eddie
you look terrible oh I have a parasite
venom
I'm Eddie Brock I'm the reporter now I
always seem to find myself questioning
something the government may not be
looking at I found something really bad
look around in the world would he see a
planet on the brink of collapse in the
games are disposable but man and soon be
combined this is a new race your species
the higher life-form
what do you want me
[Applause]
we cannot just hurt people
we have a deal eyes so many circle time
to that power it's not completely awful
you have no idea how much you're scaring
me right now walk away
and you just might survive guys you do
not want to do this trust me
we'll always come at a cost
[Music]
you will be this office will be rolling
down the street
[Music]
oh I have a parasite yeah
neighbors chant
[Applause]
[Music]